monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais associer à cette
question la sénatrice Christina Pluchet
jeudi 19 janvier jour funeste pour
l'agriculture française la Cour de
justice européenne décide de rendre
illégal les dérogations prévues pour la
filière betteraves sur l'utilisation des
néonicotinoïdes le 30 octobre 2020 votre
prédécesseur affirmé avec justesse que
la situation était perduement grave et
que tout devait être mis en oeuvre pour
protéger cette filière de même le
président de la République affirmait
haut et fort qu'il ne devait pas y avoir
d'interdit sans solution vous-même
monsieur le ministre vous m'affirmiez le
12 janvier être certain de la
reconduction des dérogations prévues
pour 2023
de plus en 2016 la France a interdit
l'usage de tous les néons nécotinoïdes
en aspersion ou en enrobage de semences
ce que l'Allemagne et tous les autres
pays s'autorisent la France est mise
dans la passe en 2020 la catastrophe de
la jeunesse de la betterave avait
occasionné 200 millions de pertes malgré
les engagements pris l'indemnisation n'a
été que de 10 à 30% du préjudice notre
souveraineté alimentaire est énergétique
et donc menacée quelle réponse concrète
le gouvernement entend apporter à cette
situation et à cette crise latente
monsieur le ministre il vous reste moins
de 10 jours pour apporter toutes les
solutions qui s'imposent car les
agriculteurs doivent prévoir la semi